Hello. Hey mark. Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich and this is
radiolab, the podcast, the podcast.
And today on the podcast we have a
story from a reporter, Mark Phillips,
who's here. Here with us. Ah, yes. Okay.
So mark, what are we hearing? Well,
I went to visit this incredible
woman named Diane. Ben. Darren. Hey,
come on man. Nice to meet you. Yeah.
Can we say what was their last name?
Van Darren van Daren. Yeah.
She lives just south of Denver in the
foothills of the rocky mountains. Oh,
that's a cool view of a extend. Very
look tiny, doesn't it? So who is she?
Why is she a person of note? Well,
she's one of the best
altar runners in the world.
Very active lives. That's an ultra runner.
The definition is just anything
longer than a marathon.
The majority of them that she runs
are a hundred miles a hundred.
This was continuous miles continuous.
There's no sleeping, no sleep,
28 hours straight. Wow. I
can tell you what pain is.
I can tell you what pain is.
And I'm, I was fortunate,
I got runner up to Lance Armstrong for
outdoor person of the year, years ago.
And I kind of think lance and I have
stories that are very parallel. How so?
Well, it's interesting,
she was always an athlete.
She actually played
professional tennis for awhile.
She came to running later
in life and oddly enough,
her running career started with a
seizure. Well, my first seizure, gosh,
I do remember it. It was
1988. Diane was 28 years old.
I had two children married. Um,
I was three weeks into my third
pregnancy and one day I was with my mom.
We were in the car and as
we were driving around,
I remember reaching for like
the, the glove compartment box.
My mom had asked for me to get some gum
out and I remember as I was reaching for
that, that's, I had this funny
sensation. It was quick and it was brief.
And then boom, that's the
last thing I remember.
And next thing she knows she's waking
up in the hospital. Um, I was confused.
I didn't know where I was, what
I was doing, what happened.
And eventually I ended up getting
with a doctor, Doctor Spitz,
and after some tests they
sent me off for an MRI.
You told her what you have is epilepsy?
Oh,
that was the first time I heard that word.
[inaudible]
the seizure is just out of the blue. Well,
what the doctors eventually figured
out is that when she was a baby,
she had a fever and I ended up
throwing a grand mal seizure,
which lasted almost an hour. That's
the, that's the big one. Yeah. And uh,
they kind of put together that she
probably damaged a part of her brain from
that seizure and 24 years later,
basically, boom, seizures.
Reoccurred and you said earlier that
this somehow led to her running? Yeah.
Okay. So after the seizure,
the first seizure in the car,
they started to happen more and more.
But before the seizures would come on,
she would have this warning
sign. It's called an aura.
I would have an or I would have a
sensation before it did go into a seizure.
People with migraine
pepper. Exactly. Yeah.
I would get really
tingly all over my body,
but feel kind of floaty the premonition
that something's about to happen.
She was in the shower, shouldn't have
to get out. Okay, what do I need to be,
what do I need to do?
And then it would happen.
I tried every medication that
was available, diets, nutrition.
I mean I tried it all.
Basically nothing was working,
nothing work until I found the only way
I could break the cycle of a seizure for
me. Whenever I had that premonition,
a seizure was coming on,
I'd have my running shoes by the
front door, should be eating dinner.
She would feel a premonition.
Just drop her, her fork and knife,
throw those running shoes on.
And I just showed you these
mountains here by my house.
I'd run to the pikes national
forest. Have this just a,
this is run in silence for a second.
Okay. So we can get some sound of that.
Yeah. Are House is literally, you know,
on the foothills of these mountains.
I'm not going to see a herd of elk out
here. I've seen them out lying out here.
Well I do, whenever I had a seizure
coming on, I'd go run. Well,
of course my family, my mom, everybody
was panicking because they thinking,
oh my gosh, Diane is going to be off
running in the middle of nowhere,
have a seizure and we're not going
to where she is, how to find her,
what we're going to do.
But I found that, um,
that it worked. She wasn't having
seizures. So when she would run,
she would have a premonition but
no actual seizure at the end. Yeah.
When I ran from the seizures
and I'd run to the forest,
I would just feel me just getting more
relaxed. My heart wouldn't be pounding,
calmness set in and that is
where my love for running began.
She did this for years. She feel this or,
and then she'd just run
literally outrunning the
seizures and at first had just
been hour or so, but then she was
going for longer and longer, two hours,
five hours, six hours. And
it sort of worked for awhile.
But eventually
the seizures basically to start
overcoming, they caught up with her.
I was having three to
five seizures a week.
I wasn't getting those premonitions
like I did in the beginning.
It got to the point where she didn't
have enough time to get her running shoes
and I didn't have that long of a
premonition. It was like boom seizure.
So I could tell that part of my brain
was actually getting weaker and I knew at
that point in time I really was at more
of a risk of dying from a seizure you
could die from is if a
seizure happens all the time.
People die of seizures all the time.
For example, um, a friend of mine,
his wife, she went up to go take a bath,
had a seizure when up later and he found
her dead in the tub. You know, my kids,
I always had a tell them, hey, mom's
taken a bath. Come check on me.
My children at a very young age had to
learn how to drive a car because what if
mom had a seizure while she was
driving? I as a parent, as a wife,
as a mom of three small children,
I was running out of options.
And you know, she talked with
her doctors and they said, well,
there's a chance you could have
a surgery that would fix this.
If the seizures are coming from
just one discrete part of the brain,
they can cut that part of the brain out,
but first they have to figure out if
it's that type of seizure and it's coming
from to see if it was operable,
which meant she had to go to the hospital
and actually have a seizure in front
of them.
I had to have 64 electrodes basically
glued onto onto my scalp and then I had
this cord out of each one of these
electrodes that was in my head.
It was tethered into a TV set.
She was hooked up to an EEG machine and
had a camera on me 24 seven and there's
footage of this. She showed it to me.
I remember laying there in
the bed saying, I can't run.
I need to let it happen.
[inaudible]
what you see on the screen is she starts
to jerk. She's clenched, she's shaking.
You hear the bed started rattling.
She bites her tongue so hard that, you
know, there's just this pool of blood,
the lower phase, he's
choking on a blood. It's,
it's, it's horrifying. Yeah.
Huh.
And then as I came out
of it, honest to God,
I felt like I'd been run over by a truck.
I was gurgling still on
some blood that was, um,
in my throat and I had a massive headache
and put the doctors are standing right
next to her cheering. All right.
All right. We got it. We got it.
Cause they actually found that the
seizures were coming from one spot in the
brain. Then when they said,
well, what do you think?
We found the spot you could be a
surgery candidate. I mean, you know,
it's a big risk and it's not like
just taking a pill. I mean you're,
you're cutting out a chunk of your brain.
Was it a tough decision or was
it just sort of a no brainer,
no pun intended? Let's see
here. Well in all honesty,
um, it was hands down.
I was like, let's go.
Hello.
So they saw the side
of my right head open.
I just literally just sod
it open. And so there was,
my brain exposed was on the table.
So the doctors huddle around and they
look in and they can actually see this
gray discolored spot from
all the seizure activity.
It's on the back right side. It's a part
of the brain called the temporal lobe,
which is the part of the brain that
seems to be involved in memory,
spatial reasoning and in temporal
reasoning time. And they had to know,
decide, okay, well how much of her
brain are we going to take out?
And they go back and forth.
I mean obviously the more
brain that they take out,
the more consequences,
the more side effects.
Well they ended up cutting out pry the
size of a kiwi out of my right temporal
lobe. That's big. Yeah,
it's not insignificant.
Kiwis are like the size of
golf balls. Right. And bigger.
When I came home I just had horrific
headaches and this extreme pain.
I just remember just holding my head,
just trying to hold my head together.
It just hurts so bad than that. And
seizure wise, they didn't know. Um,
so everybody was kind of on pins and
needles. Did it work? Did it not work?
And as days went on,
they waited and waited and waited
and I wasn't having seizures.
None at all. No, she's not had a seizure
since the night before the surgery.
So you didn't really get into the
competitive altar running until after the
surgery. How did that come about?
I mean, how did I get into this?
It was interesting. I did a 50
mile race. I won that late. Okay.
Here's where things
kind of get interesting.
After a year or so of have no seizures,
Diane decided to enter this race,
a 50 miler. Wow. On a whim. I just
read about it in a magazine, you know,
I love to run and I thought, Oh man,
I have this new outlook on life
and that one of seizures. Okay,
I'm going to write a 50 oh one that.
And then I sent it for my first hundred
mile race. Of course everybody was like,
oh my gosh. Erasing the big horn
mountains of all places. Um,
did well I ended up placing
at the same time back home.
When did you start to
notice, uh, you know,
that that things were different
working differently in your brain? Um,
[inaudible]
okay.
Oh, I didn't, my family
started noticing things.
Mom's forgetting. You know what time
my appointments were relate to school.
Mom's not here to pick me up. So she
was having short term memory loss. Yeah.
A lot of meeting somebody in the
morning. Later on that afternoon,
maybe I see him again and I have no
idea who they were. They'll have to say,
hey, remember I saw you? Those
kinds of things. But um, let's see.
What was I saying? Meanwhile,
first overall on the Alfred Packer 50
miler second overall and the bear 100
miler and first overall on the Tahoe
rim 100 miler. I can keep going. Yeah,
go first. Overall,
on the 24 hours in Frisco trial run
first for women's in the dances with the
dirt 50 miler in hell, Michigan
dances with the dirt in hell.
Michigan first and women's in the Canadian
death race, 78 mile are in Edmonton,
Canada. The Canadian death race? Yeah.
The Yukon article two or 300 miler was
minus 48 degrees when we began the event.
The shoes literally froze on my
feet and only two of us finished.
I ran the first hundred miles
with no water did for him.
30 miles in the Yukon pulling a
sled during which time she'd sleep.
Only about an hour a night for 10 days.
Wow. Really, the crazy thing is that
through all of this, she can't read a map.
What do you mean woo?
One of the main functions of that Kiwi
size part of her brain that the doctors
took out, as I said,
was spatial reasoning,
and so after the surgery maps
just look weird to her. It's,
it's like just a bunch of information
on a piece of paper. All those lines,
all those squiggles, just noise to them.
How does she navigate through a race?
Well, I take a pink ribbon with me,
so when I'm out in the middle of nowhere
and I have three ways to hit a trail,
I'm not quite sure which way to go.
Is it left it right? I'll pick away.
I'll drop a ribbon, I mean
after a couple of hours,
if she feels like she's
not on a trail anymore,
she just goes back until
she gets to the pink ribbon.
And then she picks the other way on the
Yukon. There was time where, um, gosh,
I was lost for two hours while I was
out in the middle of nowhere, all alone.
Huge heavy winds just ripping
across the Yukon River. Um,
did you win that year that you
were lost for two hours? Yeah.
Yeah.
Mostly Diane finds these
sort of workarounds for what
she lost in the surgery,
but the fact is she only became this
amazing runner after the surgery.
So while we were talking I just couldn't
help but wonder. Well, I wonder like,
do you think,
did having part of your brain removed you
obviously make you an alternate runner
and you did understand the question?
I do. Um, and she says, no.
I think having a brain injury
puts me at a disadvantage.
Um, I,
let's see, what was I saying? But, um,
I think for me that the one advantage,
if I had to say I have an advantage over
the other athletes would be, um, time,
time.
I can really get lost in time when the
doctors are moved that part of your
brain, they took out a basic awareness of,
of time passing times, hearts. So when
I'm on the Yukon, I'm going for 10 days.
I kind of forget how many days
I've been out there. You know,
some of the racers are saying,
Oh, I've been out here six days.
I'm exhausted for me, I can't look back.
I can't think you know how long I've
been running cause I don't know.
Stay in the moment
because of that. She doesn't, she doesn't
know how tired she should feel. Huh?
Think about it. If you don't
know where you are in time,
you don't know how much further you
have to go, how far you've been.
You just running,
you just hear in your footsteps and
that's it. I get a rhythm in my mind.
That's what I want to hear
with my feet. I go by rhythm.
I know the sound that my feet about
what an eight minute pace would be.
How my feet would say. Yeah.
So count half the beat for me.
You're a drummer here. Yeah.
And even with my breath into, oh,
this all breathing and
feet. Y'All go together.
[inaudible] smooth your seat, your
swimming and your gait move in your run.
So how does the breath
and the feet interact?
I just know him to press and to press out.
Match my feet.
Let's get the rhythm. Yeah.
That's all I have to here. 28 hours.
That's what I want. It's
music. That's my music.
So nothing else in my mind.
I'll put my feet up, rhythm,
my breathing. That's the music, timber
and athletes here. That's the flow.
Thanks mark. Yeah, no
problem. Border Mark Phillips.
For more information on Diane van
and you can go to our website,
radiolab.org we've got some links
there. And, uh, I guess that's it.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.